previously on TV sentence Jimmy am you
lost my looks and personality double
threat guy
I'm never getting married poor doc
Shepard also remember you pee in the
united paramount network yeah well it
eventually became part of the CW so
consider me not surprised that the pilot
kicks off with some fur raw narration is
this guy wearing black socks with his
cheating on wife road because that is
definitely a sin also adultery this
motel tryst it is what it is make it
quick
that's foreplay and she can't leave
until she gets the money shot you're
narrating in the third person now that's
just asking for the sin giver to
exponentially increase his sin cow for
your sake and his here's an extra
sixteen cents you do realize you
narrated that out loud right cause
trouble miss you see it's hilarious that
he would say that because we don't know
anything about any of these characters
yet and him being there means absolutely
nothing to us and then the fact that
she's also there is still a complete
mystery but also he said that thing
about having car trouble when she
obviously doesn't and oh she was crazy
opening theme song isn't smooth man I
hope Wallace at least has a cup or maybe
some bikini briefs on under that duct
tape because if not he's about to find
out why duct tape it's not a pleasant
thing Veronica Veronica Mars rule
commercials
Veronica Mars should be good just gonna
go ahead and point out that wait too
many people call him as Mars by her full
name it's not like there's a run on
Veronica's at Neptune huh the only
reason I was allowed past the velvet
ropes was Duncan Kane son of software
billionaire Jake Kane used to be my
boyfriend my favorite part about lazy
pilots is the endless on the news
character exposition you don't get what
what you get that you're a dead man
walking look Percy DAGs the third has
his moments but he's no Sean Penn this
time I care what a woman has to say when
she's riding my big old Hall so it's big
huh legend though big dick energy if
your dad has time do it cliff has the
worst case of radio voice I've heard in
a long time I'll be praying for his
family and this time of need let's all
hope together for a cure and get the
wrong idea mr. Mars
I hate the fact that I'm here I love
Veronica Mars old school sleuthing
approach as much as the next Neptune er
but there's a reason characters don't
talk like femme fatales from the 40s
that often anymore sounds ridiculous in
a modern-day setting and Lisa Thornhill
isn't exactly changing my mind here
don't call me at home I'll call you I'll
need it right away
sounds like mrs. cane might actually be
talking about Keith's big hog
when you go after Jake Kane take backup
this could be argued as being the most
ridiculous father/daughter relationship
ever in a TV show but that doesn't mean
it's not also one of the best friend has
a secret that you never get to hear
because they die before they can tell
you and you spend an entire season of a
show trying to solve his or her murder
cliche everyone knows the story the
murder of Mickey well I don't but
thankfully you're reading it to me off
the script in a vocal booth somewhere so
I can catch up quick also any show that
kills a man decipher it in the first 15
minutes deserves every sin it gets
bungling sheriff is my dad man the
exposition is just coming hard and heavy
now and with adjectives like bungling
I'm pretty sure my dad the bungling
sheriff was a 1960s sitcom starring Don
Knotts and no amount of your so-called
googling is gonna convince me otherwise
who's a child
now there's a euphemism for you visit
the infirm ISM for that thing where
you're sure there's a little more you
can strain out but it keeps retreating
back inside anyway holy streaming video
made it possible someone made a fortune
while dad took the blame Veronica Mars
pilot creepily predicts the
proliferation of YouTube content your
dad is destroying the Kane family okay
so I get that soap operas have to soak
their operas and although this show is
laying it on super thick we've gone from
quippy snark to soft focus murder
accusations in like five minutes
[Music]
News position I swear I'm getting to the
point of your TV show or movie doesn't
have this position in it I'll remove us
it can't be not only are we engaged
fully in a show starts in the middle and
eventually finds its way back there
cliche this particular show has decided
we need to see this 90 seconds of film
completely repeated as if we couldn't
hold on to that information for 20
minutes all right
one week after that we come for you your
boy and your little dog too
taking The Wizard of Oz and Bane you
want to know how I lost my virginity so
do I so we're adding an unsold rape to
the list of things the show is trying to
hook us in with geez save some info for
episode two Duncan will promise to take
his shirt off sweeten the pot welcome
back to Veronica's Amar's and men are
from penis this matter and she a
mother's daughter and there was a woman
who dream okay look I know these
[ __ ] are in a social strata that I
couldn't even imagine and maybe they
talk about their parents and their
wealth like that but this mother is
seriously calling out Veronica's mom for
being an alcoholic what high schooler
makes that kind of insult it's been a
months since I've seen my mother when do
we get to the part of this show that
isn't melodramatic and depressing is
that coming up soon no one will be
seated during the Veronica prints off
compromising pictures while listening to
the streets portion of the episode who's
your daddy just shoot me exam Blue
Oyster Cult the eight-track of Foxy stat
blonde riding shotgun racing for pink
slips I don't know which bothers me more
foxy or stacked well both are clearly
racist but I'm gonna be honest here I'm
about to take away a sin for Kristen
Bell because she's an absolute treasure
and when this show is leaning on her
snarkiness more than her darkness it
absolutely wins also side note how are
we not having conversations about the
Kristin's like we do about the Chris's
Stuart Bell wig Chenoweth let's see salt
okay I'm just saying we're close well if
it isn't smoky the barely legal name
equal parts disgusted and impressed with
that line but mostly discussed it that
car is registered to one Lianne Mars
don't don't
duh particular you'd like me to arrest I
just round up the sons the most
important families in town if you're
gonna make the police this villainous
you should at least give him a moustache
to twirl
cops love moustaches hi Your Honor is
this an appropriate time to ask for
dismissal in People vs Loretta Cancun
cool so since Veronica hated this
[ __ ] she helped this [ __ ] get
these two [ __ ] off for the [ __ ]
crimes they actually [ __ ] committed
all to get on the good side of this
[ __ ] to keep this [ __ ] in check
are we having fun yet Veronica yeah ha
oh come on
find out in a few seconds that the rich
boys are hanging out by our car but
instead of just saying that Wallace uses
the automotive version of the pronoun
game to keep the audience guessing who's
your daddy this is truly the bad place
still I've got too many questions
swirling around in my head I can't wait
to see all of them answered and for
Veronica to find peace in the next few
episodes the first season before it's
canceled in the movie in the novel's
why would you do this to me are you that
you could do this that's what girl
friendly if she said everybody dies but
us everybody dies but us we gonna carry
on and plan the secret cause let's face
it baby these days
God Lily I see the prozac working like a
happy SPN or something my breasts can
always tell when it's gonna rain
someone from the Sheriff's Department
leaked the crime-scene video within 24
hours it was all over the net with that
girl from the bus one week after that we
come for you your boy